okay so you have uh the fourier
coefficient
of uh of the restricted function um
so it's interesting to see and quoted
the um
the rate on this fourier coefficient
expectedly over there
um so we have a reminder right here
uh up here um what is exactly the
fourier uh transform of
this fourier coefficient as a function
of z
so we can use it uh to calculate to this
to do this calculation
and then we have uh the perceval
that let us uh take just the
the rate of the function f and it lies
on the characters
that their live variables are exactly uh
t
okay so in this is simple and another
interesting random variable
which we can think what is its value is
a
rate on level k of the restricted
functions
as we said we want the rate to be on
level one so
what is level k weight this is just the
fourier coefficient the weight of the
four coefficients of characters
of size k um
so we can we can just calculate this
it's
very easy to calculate we just take all
the characters of size k
of the restricted function and take what
we calculated before
uh and all the summations together
um it's exactly the rate
of the fourier er of the fourier
present fourier transform of f the first
spectrum of f
uh of on characters that have exactly
k alive variables
so it actually actually depends only on
j
um so
let's take it level up there on
domination and
random also j what happened if we take
j and randomize it um
so how can we random j just choose every
variable to stay alive with some
probability
let's say mu and
now we again we get the set of variables
of the alive variables it's j it's
random we don't know
what variables are going to stay alive
and we also uh
choose random zen the assignment for the
uh for the other characters uh we again
get a
random function that now it it's double
random we get
both j and z is random which means that
even the
the variables that it works on even the
number of variables is a random
is a random variable it depends on j and
z
so we can think about uh interesting
random variables to calculate
so for example uh let's see
let's think about how many uh variables
uh if the function the restricted
function depends on
which is the size of j it's easy to
calculate
we have n variables each one and chosen
chose read the probability mu so we have
new fraction of the variables
even more we can look at any character
in
f and think whether
it's stay alive or not or how many
variables in it
stay alive so
for example we can think about uh
encounter and
what is expected uh size of
s intersecting j
and this is how many alive variables
uh left form s this is again
will be exactly a new fraction of the
variables in
s so what we have here
is that large characters
with appropriate random restriction
might be much smaller if we want a
character
to to get to the first fourier level
we have to choose mu in appropriate way
for example if s is of size d
we take mu to be one over d and then we
will expect
the only one variable from s to stay
aligned
and the weight we have on
on s in the function f will go
uh all the way down to the first level
so oh my god okay um
random okay so what we have here
um so let's calculate again the
the level k weight for some k
and now for both j and z are
uh random
so we can use what we calculated before
the
the level k rate for random z once we
know j
and and then we get uh
that it is it's actually
the uh the rate of the characters
that are rated with the probability of
them
to to to end up in the
level k every character
uh contribute its uh
weight to level k with probability
that it will have exactly k alive
variables
let's see an example if we think about
homogeneous function of degree exactly d
so we can choose
every variable to stay alive with
probability one over d
and then we get that every character
has constant probability
to to end up on the first four-year
level
this way we will have that the expected
rate on the first fourier level for the
restrictions of this function
uh the appropriate restriction is one
over the probability to stay alive
is constant we can take this uh
this example and relax it a little we
don't need
in order to have a constant
rate on the first fourier level
expectedly with
mu one over d we don't need the function
to be
exactly of the greedy we can think about
functions that are approximate degree d
in some sense uh so let's think about
another example
if f is close to a homogeneous function
of the greedy
what do i mean that i say close to
homogeneous function of degree d
if it has constant uh
weight on degree exactly d
we still will have a constant
rate on on the first fourier level of
the restrictions expectedly
okay because all the uh the
rate of degree d constant part
of it constant fraction of it is going
down to the
first fourier level so it's enough that
we have their constant
and redux is the notion of homogeneous
of degree exactly d
um and here we can see the difference
between
uh using the log sobolev and the
hyper-contractive
to use the hyper-contracting we need
exactly degree here in this
uh example we may we might have
some weight even in degree n but it's
enough that we have
constant rate on degree d let's see
another example
um let's think about another notion of
uh approximate degree d
we don't only need the uh
the constant rate to be exactly on
degree d
it's enough that it's uh the constant
rate is on
levels around d that the
characters that are of size
approximately the
constant times d of them together
have constant rate and then for every
character of this set
of size approximately d
we have constant probability uh that
only that exactly one variable will stay
alive
will be in j um
so why why it's interesting to think
about uh
functions of approximate degree d so
first of all we know how to do random
restriction to
uh to take uh to take them to their
first four-year level and then we know
what to do with functions with
a small degree and
it it's common to uh
it's interesting because we can do uh
with every
function we we can find some d where it
has
uh enough degree so
um you can
you can think about any function and
then
with the the attic uh partition we can
you can
part it to uh to look at the
zero to nf and then have to end
and see where do you have uh more
weight and then do something like
binary search to find the right d that
you have enough rate so
we are not expected for every function
to be
constant but not so small
we might find some d that we have
one over log n fraction of the weight
on um around d
on levels uh that are approximately d
um
[Music]
we we may assume for for now we will
assume that we have
exactly the exactly uh that we have some
d that we have constant
uh constant right there but uh
but you can see that that even one over
log n is not so
small and might be enough in some cases
so it's reasonable to think about
functions like this
okay
so just a reminder what is the degree d
function
approximately d we this is a function
that a pro
on approximate d we have uh
enough weight uh which i mean constant
rate
so this is the first assumption that i'm
doing uh
to cheat um i take the function that we
want
uh i just remind you that i want we want
to to prove the cake and term
and we find some d where
around there we have uh
the maximal weight the did it maximize
the rate
and now we assume that it's constant
instead of
one over log n
so let's do the random restriction with
the mu
equal one over d we want all the the the
rate from degree around d
to drop to level one
um so as we calculated we have now
for uh for random gen z uh
um constant rate on on first for eleven
and that means that there is some
j uh that maximizes this uh
um this weight
and we can fix from now on we can fix
this j
and work with a random z
we just know now that there is some j
that have this
and now uh let's see what we have
if if we can say that for
every zed there is a
we can we can find that that that have
that are very close to
dictatorships for example and
if we think about it
if it will be the case that all the
restrictions
uh or enough restrictions many
restrictions will have
the structure of uh of dictatorship and
they have
they will have the same dictatorship
it's mean that
actually this dictatorship uh this
variable
that all of them chose uh is actually
very influential for every sub cube
that there is that the determined uh
um some j to be the dictatorship
it's very influential in this hub cube
with and if we have
uh many sub cubes that same variable
is the dictatorship there this variable
has
a large influence
so we can think of it that uh
that's what we need in uh in the
calculator to say that there is a
variable that is very influential um
so it's enough to find enough z that
that have same
variable as their dictatorship
and otherwise if all of them are small
we have to find the total influence
large
from somewhere else we really have to
find
influential edges somewhere in the in
the cube
that is not in this dictatorships
so let's uh cheat again and assume that
for every z we have exactly
one on the first four-year level all the
rate is
there and for sure it's a very
simplified assumption
um but let's go with it
and therefore once we have all the rate
on the first fourier level
we can actually think about it that
every z
is actually uh determine some
xj to be its dictatorship
so let's go with it and i hope we'll
have some time to get rid of this
assumption
but let's think about it
[Music]
so for now we can think about every z
and j as a some associations are mapping
from z to j
and let's partition the cube uh
as um in the way that
every then all the sets that choose
the same variable to be their
dictatorship
so let's put all of them together uh
in a group we'll call this group a j a k
a l as which dictatorship they chose
so all the the restrictions that chose
some
xj um are together
and now we can think where are the
the influ what is the influential edges
uh
around in the in the cube so either
um the influential edges are
inside the this partition if there is a
group
which is large all of this
all the zeds that in in some group
have the same uh the same dictatorship
and this is an influential bit for all
of this input so if it's large
we have uh the
large influence you can see that also
every z we have exactly equality here
the density of aj is exactly
the influence of the variable j because
inside aj
xj is influential because this is the
dictatorship and outside aj
we have another dictatorship so xj is
not influential
so this is exactly the probability of of
z2 being aj it's got exactly the
probability
of j to be influential and this just uh
again a reminder if it's small we are
done if it's large we are done
we have large influence so let's assume
that all of this
um subsets all of this
the partitions of aj all of them are
small
and now we we're left of uh
we have to to show that there are many
influential edges
somewhere else so what we are left with
it's only the edges between in between
the
the set and let's
note that every edge between a
some aj to other a
to another set of sets is influential
edge
almost every edge uh it's going from one
dictatorship to another dictatorship
so if the values of x j and xl are
different
then we have influential edge which
means that half of the edges
in between the between the the
subsets between the partition are
influential so in this case
we only have to show that we have
many influential edges uh or actually
that we have many
edges between those uh
subsets of the cube sub substance yes
subset of the cubes
um okay so
we actually done we just have to show
that we have a lot of uh
of edges there so let's see how we have
a lot of vegeta
there it's pretty easy uh so you're
going to use the logs obviously
inequality
and what is the observable of inequality
so we have some definition and i uh
i want to talk about it now and we have
the theorem
and we have a corollary and i will go
straight to the corollary and we'll go
back to the logs overlap
after that so from the logs over of
inequality
we can uh divide
the edge the standard as the edges of
parametric inequality
um which we know even without the logs
of relevant quality so we can
take it for our use
uh what it means that for every subset
of
uh of the of the cube which is
small uh the edge boundary of this set
is large what we have here in the edge
boundary of the set
a is at least the number
of uh of vertices in a log 1 over the
density of a so if the density of a
as we we assume is smaller than
1 over square root 10 we have here that
the number of edges in the boundary
is log n times the vertices in
in a and
what we actually have is for every
subset we have this amount of
of edges um going from inside ak to
outside so let's sum up all the edges
together so again we count to every edge
twice once from the side of uh
of ak and once and the other is from the
other uh vertex and oops
um summing down up
all of them we get it's cover all the
the hypercube so we actually get
two to the n times log n sensitive edges
which uh if we normalize it we get
exactly the average sensitivity
is larger than log n which exactly what
we wanted to
to get so what actually
the kkl theorem said is
that once you do this process either
you have some dominant
dictatorship or otherwise
you have a lot of influential edges
in between the the restrictions
so that um
i guess the example that you gave
earlier with the address function
really falls in the second case right so
like after you fix the address beats and
all the you know every dictator appears
with probability
only one over two to the k which is kind
of small it's like one over n
but the address bits are influential so
yes sure exactly address bits are very
very influential and for every change
you do you just
get another dictatorship
yeah um so i just wonder whether to
to go back to the log so but now yeah
okay i'll do that
um so so far it seems that you don't
rely on logs of olive i mean you just
rely on the edge as a permanent
inequality yes you're all right
um so why we need the logs of
uh we did a very strong assumptions here
uh we we actually
assumed that i will go back to the
assumption there
actually assumed that for every zed we
have exactly one there and
uh
and it is exactly a dictatorship which
is far from wing two
and okay now it's stuck there in
my clicks i write a little
so
okay let's continue to go back
[Music]
okay um
so we are here okay so you want to get
rid of this assumption uh
that for there are actually two
assumptions that we want to get rid of
them one of them is
that we have constant rate on the degree
approximate d when we know that we
actually have one over log n there is
some d that we have one over log n
and the other one is here that we assume
that for every z
we have exactly one what we actually
will do that are two separate
solutions um for the assumption that the
degree
is a uh that we have one exactly
weight one for everything what we will
do
we we we will use the
expected argument
we will use another function
i will show it in a minute
and and and we'll use the expected
agreement
all the functions in order to
to get large influence and
that the function that we are going to
use is um
is going to replace the function which
is the indicator
of uh of the sets
uh aj we we are not going actually to
have a
perfect set that every z have exactly
uh one variable that uh
that it's uh choose as a dictatorship we
really have
used the uh having the uh
the constant rate on the first four year
level
uh in a sense that uh that there
there is some for a lot of z
there is some fourier coefficient in the
first four year level which is a
large which is close to one and
we will expect on them and the
this is one solution i'm going to talk
about it and the other
the the other problem which we assume
that
that we have constant rate on the
uh on on the degree d
on approximate degree d uh for that we
will have another solution i guess i
will not have time to
to go into uh for it but
what we do is actually to um
to separate the the characters of f
uh two chunks from
every uh k between uh
for for every d which is the power of
two
we'll take the part of function around d
and the combination of all these
functions
is the function f we'll define on those
functions
the the total influence for example and
the summation
of all of them will be the total
influence of f and we'll analyze
every chunk separately
[Music]
and and then combine all of them
together and this is how
the place when we really need the
the logs over have inequality because we
want to combine
uh chunks of the of the function
together
and then we need the additive additivity
of the
of the expected degree so
um what we'll do now uh
we'll solve the the first problem
uh that we assumed
here all of them are the same so i have
another
presentation for it and
we'll just find it
okay it's not what you you need to see
but
one you need
okay okay so i will talk about uh about
uh about the logs of a little bit and uh
and then we'll see how to use it in
order to solve our problem
so what we have what is exactly the log
soba lab
we have the definition of the entropy
of the f squared
and now i'll try to do it alive
so we have the entropy of f squared and
and it's defined as something that looks
like the entropy
actually i don't really understand why
it's called entropy
because it's uh this is the information
left in the random variable
f squared x and it's actually
n minus the entropy of the f square dx
the shannon entropy that we which is
well known
up to some normalization and
and what log suburbs said is that this
entropy which is the information
left in the in the variable f squared
is smaller than it's bound the the
total influence from uh
uh from
it's bound to totally influence and
we worked uh actually part of the work
is
uh was to to analyze this entropy of f
the part which is the entropy of f
and in order to get a simpler corollary
which
we actually use um
which we have is uh um
instead of using the entropy which is a
little bit
harder to to use as a expected function
um we replace it with the
with norms norm2 and norm1 of f
and num1 is a little bit weird here but
uh that's how it appears in the luxon
blob
and for
for for boolean valued functions it's
not really
different because all the uh
num1 is exactly norm2 squared so
the square of num1 is exactly this this
spread known to so it would be okay
um how do you prove this quality
so it's very simple we just need uh in
order to prove this color here we just
need to um
to bound the entropy with the
uh with the norms
and the way we did it we just used the
the cauchy
words in order to simplify uh
the uh the expectation
and and and is the fact that say that
for every t it's
actually a calculated fact and that of
for every uh value here inside the
the log functions one we have the square
here
it's less than uh
the the absolute value and that's how we
get
the uh the first norm of
f um
so what is the meaning of this uh of the
logs overlap um
so maybe i will uh do it later
there is something interesting about it
as uh and the
unconcentrated um uncertainty principle
it's a pretty relatable but let's
just use it for our needs
so what we have here um
we just wanted to to simplify
uh to get rid of this assumption um
so what we do now is uh
let's analyze what happened here when we
with our assumption
so we have the restricted function which
did which said chooses the uh the
indicator
xj hatch choose it it actually choose
this uh
indicator um in its for yeah
so once it's the indicator we know
exactly how the fourier transform
uh work the the fourier coefficient of
the
singleton j is exactly one and
uh and for all the other
characters we have fourier coefficient
exactly zero
so it's very very simple uh structure
so now let's define uh the function
for every j the function gj
that actually take this uh uh
fourier coefficient as a uh function so
let's go to zero one
um it's actually say which one
is uh which one of the uh
of the variables z determined as
its uh um
dictatorship but you can see that now
it's much more flexible because we can
use
the definition of gj
you see that this is exactly the
function uh
which was the um
the indicator function of the subset
um that that determined aj
um but now we know that even if it's not
exactly one
and we don't have exactly the uh the xj
so the function gj is now going to
uh we still can use this function as
the function that said uh for each z
how much it clause to be a dictatorship
of
uh jay
and
and now we can see that
actually once the the the four-year
level on the first
the the four-year rate on the first
four-year level is actually consists of
these functions of
the gj functions the um for some z
the summation of all these functions
i'll do it actually if we fix
some g is some z the
fourier wait on the level one
for this z uh
is actually the summation of all
this function uh j
g j of z
squared okay so
we we see that now we have a very strong
connection between those functions that
are not
already uh boolean uh
with the the first fourier level of the
restriction
um so what we had here was aj
and now we are going to replace it with
gjz which acted in the
simplified assumption as the indicator
but now
we'll take it without being the
indicator but close to this
and again we want to say that
somehow mu aj that here
is the second norm of j
uh we somehow want to say that it's
still
uh small or large as we as we need
so
let's prove something about it
okay so we'll use the function gj
instead of the indicator
okay we get rid of it and
let's see what we have so this is not a
live
you see and uh okay so we have
here the definition of uh gj and
let's say um okay so
as as we we have already uh
did we have the exp we have some j
uh capital j
that is fixed that for this this j
uh the weight on the first fourier level
expectedly over z
is at least constant now
uh we'll see a very trivial uh
um lemma let's say that
actually the expected uh
the summation overall uh
j's the second norm of gj
is also at least constant
and how it works it's just because the
uh
the equality that we have that gj is
exactly the singletons
okay so now um
we want to show uh that every dj
nor squared norm is less than
the j's influence
so if if there is some uh
so the way we'll use it that if there is
some influence j which is large
again we are done and otherwise all of
them are small
smaller than say a
one over square to n
and then we
and and then we we will need to find the
total influence in other place which
will be very similar to the edges
that we have found before so how do we
prove this
uh this lemma it's actually very similar
to
uh to what we've seen before that was
the exact case
uh but but a little bit we find
so let's think about uh gj
as its definition as the fourier
coefficient
and then
and then we have we have it as
uh it's projection of
fjz on the on yj on the
variable yj this is actually the inner
product as a definition of the
fourier coefficient as we have here um
which we can separate for the cases when
y j
is one and minus n minus one and we get
that this is exactly the
uh difference between the value of f
when one j
j is 1 and y j is minus 1
over 2. this is very similar to the
influence it it's actually the
the value of the derivative function
this is maybe i need to change the color
and let's find something
okay so this is actually the
uh the derivative j of
f at the point
z y
okay so if we we analyze now the
l to square of jd um
so it's just uh expectation over z
of the values of j g uh
z which is exactly this
expectation which is actually the
derivative of j
and y squared um
and now using quotation marks we take
the square
inside the expectation
and we get exactly the influence j of
f okay so now we have
we can go uh along the way with these
gjs the the singletons coefficients
uh that are small expectedly
for every j
um
and now we need to find the total the
large total influence so
how can we find yet as again as we did
uh before
we try to find it as uh the edges
between
uh the functions so we'll do it again
like
more just more refined um
so let's see another lemma
um i need to change my color again
so the let's take all the
gj's and see that the total influence is
larger than this
the summation of all of their total
influences
uh hint we will use the log sobolev in
order to
uh to bound the total influence of
influences of gj
and then we'll sum up all of them
together and to get
bound for the total influence of f
um so again this is exactly what we did
before just gj was the indicator of
a j okay so how can we
see that um so the total influence of
f is larger than the influences
individual on influences of on that are
not
in jed in j that is the influences of
the variables
that are not alive the variables that
are in there and the restriction
um which are each one of them
here we use dilemma each one of them is
larger than
uh the influences actually it's
uh maybe it is equality here
um the all the influences of i over gj
no i'm not sure it's quality it somehow
takes the
um all the influences over
uh all the directions and
some of them together
it's not equality just because of some
norms that are num1 norm2 and
things like this um
but technique technically it's close to
the equality
and and what is it i ask it to go back
to the previous slide i forgot what was
written yes
sure here or no no
one with the lemma yes
so we had this lemma that said we we
think
okay the the the uh the idea here to uh
to think about gj as the function that
said
uh for every cell to uh whether it's
close to either or j
or not so it's not
it's not the the case but it's easier to
think about it like this
and then for every j expectedly over
z we have uh uh at most the
the influence of j
okay and now all we involved with
the are the gjs that are
actually the uh what i did
um that actually there are the
uh the singletons coefficients
and uh
and either we have one of them which is
large
or otherwise we have their total
influences together
are large
okay thank you
okay um
let's go look there
and
okay so here we have a
a lower bound for the total influence
and
only what we we left with is just to
lower bound
uh this part once we know about this
part
uh we are done we just need to say this
is larger than log n
and that's enough so um
let's see how we do it
i think that uh the produce
slide
um okay so we will go
back here uh to our coloring of the log
so blur
and reapply we'll apply it
we'll apply this for every gj
so we have the total influence of f
is larger than a
summation over j
in j and
this uh this amount for every
gj so this is f
and gj l two squared norm
log one over g j
delta squared now minus four
g j
l squared and g j
first known to the half um
okay so the summation is is in the
beginning i will put it here
instead of using the uh
the constant i like to omit constant
aj nj
um so now what we know about
this may be complicated thing
and so the first thing we know that we
want it to be large
and and this is because we assumed
something is small so what we know this
is small just a remainder here uh
g j delta squared norm was smaller than
the influence j
which we assumed smaller than one over
square root n
so we can see that we have here where we
change the color
and we have here a nice bound
okay we have the gj l2 squared which we
know that is small
so here is our log n
you can put it okay i'll just replace it
with logan
hope you're okay with it
and another thing we have
this summation we already talked about
this summation this is
it's actually count all the uh fourier
eight on the first fourier level
so all of them together are the uh
variance of f or actually the uh
the weight on the level d of f
um i'll put here uh
i'll put here the rate of level dff
because it's more
accurate
level around d of f but let's think
about it as a
constant and what we we now want
to see that the other cement here
doesn't cancel it so it's enough to show
that it is
small if it's small enough we are done
yep so that's that's what we are going
to see
this amount is uh small and that's how
we use the log supplement quality in
order to
um to combine uh
functions uh together all the gjs
together the influence
their influences um and get the
the influence actually the expected
degree of them with the expected degree
of
f okay this is uh um the power of logs
overlap it's here
this is a point um so let's just
um for uh for things to be complete for
completeness
uh sure that this is uh small
so i will do it here i hope i have
enough
space and so we have the summation over
j um
and this is i just i'm going to use the
crochet schwarz inequality in order to
separate them
from the summation separate both the
the second norm and the first norm so
it's smaller than the summation over
g j l two squared
and summation over g j
l one
okay so what we already know from here
is that the first
um multiplicative there
is a small this is same what we had here
so we have here the
uh square root of
level d uh
fourier transform fourier weight of f
and
here we can think about it as um
the okay in the same way that we have
we have seen that the l two squared norm
of j
g is smaller than the influence
uh we can show exactly same proof
that the first norm of jg is less than
the first norm so let's do less than
the first norm of
of the derivative function on the j the
j direction um
l unknown okay it's exactly the same
proof
and for we assume that
f f is is boolean so l one ohm of
the derivative function of f is exactly
as
the influence of f of the
i of the jc influence of f as the l two
squared norm
so we can put here actually the total
influence
so we have here the total inference of f
and now it's uh it's clear that
this term is much smaller than uh
say the total influence that we have in
the other side this is the square root
of it
uh so we can just omit it
and actually we are done
um we had the
we have the the total influence which is
large um
okay so in purpose i left here the
around d
so what we do now is just to separate
the function f to chunks that as the
addict
partition and for every chunk we do
this the same and sum up all of them
together
so it's not exactly what i said because
the main problem here
is that the chunks are going to be
not booleaned and even
maybe not
bounded values um
but we we go over
we go on this uh these problems
um it's not so hard but i will not go
into it now so any questions about the
proof
before i'm going uh some summary
so maybe you can mention where did you
use the booleanity
word mention where did you use bulianity
um so the last step that i used bulanity
was
here to to go uh
first for from the the
norms one of the influences of the
derivative functions
to uh
cannot start your video okay
you will not have to see me um okay so
this is a place and actually it's
crucial uh
because what we actually did where we
proved the kcal term for
bounded functions and not for not
only for a boolean
functions and then another thing that we
did on the
on the kkl is um
is that did we prove it actually uh
um okay so now you see me uh
we we prove it uh for
l one uh influences which are
actually the the exactly same as the
influences
just to take the derivative function
instead of uh
or take it on the l two squared you take
the l1 ohm
and also the total influence and this
version of the kegel
let us use bounded functions
uh and uh and it's actually it turned
out that it seems
not to be true for a l for l2
influences but when we go back to the
boolean functions it's the same so
so actually it's okay but in our proof
we we actually need
the uh the non-boolean version which is
uh
for uh uh bounded
uh bound infections and this is how we
we make the chunks we we divided
the um the function
okay so so you prove that
there exists an influential coordinate
with respect to
l1 influences and then you derive
yes and otherwise uh the l1 total
influence is large yes
exactly the same yeah and
okay i'll go back to my first
okay just
just for summary um and go back
there
okay i hope my screen is not going to
dead again um okay so another thing that
i can't use my computer now but i will
talk uh
another thing that i want to talk about
is how to use these techniques for
other things um
so for example uh
one can try to to prove
another statement um
okay how do i do it now
um
[Music]
one minute sorry the quality is
so we can use these techniques uh try to
okay i don't have light okay
um you can use
these techniques uh try to
uh to prove uh tolerance by bungain
or for your entropy influence conjecture
i want to talk about it a little
and actually
there are some proofs for other uh
statements um i think it's not yet
published but they're
but they are on the way uh about the for
the
the techniques that are used for the
fourier entropy influence conjecture
um once we have the log sublime
inequality we can try to use induction
on the
bot the the influence and the entropy
and to combine them
back together and
there are some ways to to do inductions
on
boolean functions there are some proofs
and uh
in the field that are like this and
maybe this approach will help so what do
we have about the logs over of
inequality
is that actually you can write it the
uh an equivalent version of this
is somehow look like the
uncertainty principle and this is
actually equivalent
to the log server that we've seen uh it
says that
either the total influence is large
or the entropy the shannon entropy of
the values
squared the is large
and i like to uh
to think about it
also with the the uncertainty principle
itself
um which says that either the entropy of
the values
or the entropy of the fourier is large
and actually we have uh in the log
several events are important in
principle
the same lower bound for the total
influence and
the fourier entropy which means that in
some
cases when the enter shannon entropy of
the values is very small
we actually have the
[Music]
the fourier entropy influence
it's already known from some classes of
boolean functions but this is something
very interesting
that's what i have meanwhile to say
about it
so i'll go back to the questions maybe
someone have a question or you want to
see summary
or we we are a lack of time actually
thank you for the great talk i guess
yeah it's a good time
to ask questions okay
someone here other questions in the q a
no
so i i have a question about um
so in the case when uh so you
uh initially were assuming that all of
the
support was near degree d then you're
dividing it up into the different levels
when you assumed it was near d
you were choosing random restrictions
with roughly one over d
so are you doing different weight random
restrictions
different values for different portions
of the function
and then combining them together yes
exactly that's what we do
we for every chunk for every d we want
to take all
uh as much weight that we can drop it to
the first fourier level
analyze it get that we have large
influence there
and then combine all of them together to
get large influence for f
is exactly yeah okay
so if you don't have other questions
so good night for me it's 10 a.m it's 10
p.m here
and i'm in the office thank you este it
was really great
thank you
all right